لم نفقد أحداً بسبب فيروس كورونا
في الولايات المتحدة
، ولا أحد ، وهذا لا يعني أننا لن
نكون جاهزين لأي
ظرف من الظروف ، ونأمل ألا
يكون ذلك ظرفًا كبيرًا ،
ولكن مهما كانت
الظروف
نحن  أعدت الاستعداد ، هذا هو الجهد الأكثر
عدوانية وشمولية لمواجهة
فيروس أجنبي في التاريخ الحديث ، فإن
أمريكا مرة
أخرى وسرعان ما تكون مفتوحة للعمل ،
سيكون
هذا سيئًا للغاية لمدة أسبوعين وربما حتى ثلاثة
أسابيع ، سيستغرق هذا ثلاثة أسابيع
مثل  لم نر من قبل ،
لذا مع الأقنعة ، سيكون
حقًا أمرًا تطوعيًا
يمكنك القيام به ، ولا يتعين عليك القيام بذلك ، فأنا أختار عدم
القيام بذلك ولكن قد يرغب بعض الأشخاص في القيام
بذلك وهذا أمر
جيد  رئيس الولايات المتحدة
هو صاحب القرار إذا لم نكن هنا من أجل
الولايات ،
لكانت قد واجهتك مشكلة في هذا
البلد كما لم ترها من قبل من قبل
سيكون كل شيء في حالة
جيدة جدًا قريبًا جدًا سنكون في
شكل جيد جدا قريبا جدا
ستكون هناك جيوب من النار وسنطفئها ،
هذا سيختفي بدون
لقاح سيختفي
ولن نراه مرة أخرى
ونأمل بعد فترة من الوقت
تكون الأرقام ضئيلة للغاية
مقارنةً بما كان
عليه الحال عندما تختبر إلى
هذا الحد ،
ستجد المزيد من الأشخاص الذين
ستعثر عليهم في المزيد من الحالات ،
لذلك قلت لشعبي إبطاء الاختبار ،
من
فضلك الحكام يعملون معي.
أعمل مع الحاكم ، نحن نعمل
جنبًا إلى جنب ، أعتقد أننا جميعًا
مسؤولون ، أعتبره كفريق
نحصل على درجات عالية جدًا بشأن
فيروس الصين هذا ، ما كان يجب أن يأتي إلى
هنا
أبدًا ، ما كان يجب أن يأتوا إلى هنا
أبدًا.  سمحت بحدوث ذلك
إذا فزت ، وآمل أن أفوز ، فكيف لا يمكنك ذلك
عندما ترى أرقامًا مثل هذه
على الفيروس والاقتصاد ، أعني أننا
يجب أن نفوز ، يجب علينا جميعًا
أن نحافظ على هذا الشيء المذهل
في العمل الذي قمنا به  تم إنجازه أمر لا يصدق واه
لا نحصل على أي ائتمان مقابل ذلك ولكننا  لقد
قاموا بعمل مذهل
، وقالوا كيف قلت إننا حصلنا على ميزة
إضافية ، لكنني حصلت على درجة عالية
في العلاقات العامة ، فإن نهاية
الوباء وشيكة ، وسيكون العام المقبل
أحد أعظم السنوات في تاريخ بلدنا
[الموسيقى]